bonjour bonjour bonjour il est un jeu
biechlin
et bien aujourd'hui nous allons vous
faire un plat très traditionnelle qu les
mousquetaires ont dû manger ici même
puisque d'artagnan vrai d'artagnan
qu'est-ce que tu dois delà du mans est
né à côté lisse si la poule au pot et
mesdames messieurs vous pensez par vous
savez tous faire la pole pour la poule
gasconne pour la faire très bonne il
faut beaucoup de choses maïté il ya
plein de choses que vous avez mis là
pour faire cette poule
alors il faut tout d'abord et de jolies
poule 4 grâce si on peut choisir
il faut 100 fois il faut son coeur sans
gésiers il faut du jambon de la
ventrèche qui se trouve là il faut des
os il faut du thème du un oignon avait
des projets rohff l'échalote de l'aïe
dit persine du père assis du lait il
faut du poireau il faut des carottes
il faut de navets il faut tordre jolis
chevaux mais ensuite il faut du riz il
faut du sel du poivre bien entendu de la
farine du beurre des cornichons du
citron 2 e et qu'est ce que c'est que
cette indigne on l'a de la ficelle pour
lui coudre le derrière la machine bien
entendu pour faire le hachis et tout ça
pour faire une poule farcie et ben ça
n'était pas si simple on attaque on
attaque alors ma idc gésiers qu'est ce
que tu veux en faire voilà alors le
gésier on le coupe parce qu'en mai aps
entièrement en coupe justement loeb je
sais pas comment s'appelle en faveur du
gésier lolobo loge comment fait on l'a
baptisé comment veut ça et pourquoi ce
concours est ce que les virus sasser que
d'une ère c'est que toute annonce et
c'est un non événement voila apres en
mai le jambon la ventrèche que voici
voilà il y en a c'est en mai les chats
l'autre que l'on écoute
ah oui vue la poupée un petit peu en
deux entre 4,2 live te fais aussi un peu
pareil où je vais vous faire un petit
peu voilà un emprunt passera choir quand
même on va mettre le persil voilà et
tout ça on arrêtera son choix
oh mais de tous
ici on va faire tourner voilà c'est tout
pour moi et le persil ensuite parce que
j'aurais préféré même être perçue oui
dieu pour qu'il perde plus facilement qu
on puisse couper là et l'oeil et de la
musique
allez on tourne pendant tout le jeu
tourner la manivelle bon escient maïté
ça va nous faire la base de la farce en
somme
ensuite il va falloir la compléter à
compléter avec votre père trempé dans le
lait maïté tu passes le pain oui dans la
moulinette aussi bien sûr alors il a été
bien trempé émietté dans le lève là il
va pousser le fas du hachis tout ça va
sortir à la loi et les faits la
moulinette ça y est c'est bon
et ensuite ce hachis ce je suis unique
un snuff dedans entier cuit et on
mélange avec les doigts parce que ça va
beaucoup mieux et tu ajoutes ensuite
c'est loin c'est pour le sel poivre et
le sel pas tellement parce que les
jambes on attend alors peu salé le salé
ainsi de poires oui et ça y est ce sera
terminé ça y est on va mettre le poivre
parce que recel et non je pense que la
ventrèche n'a jamais semblé bien voilà
c'est prêt oui même sort à supporter un
soupçon de plus de peine pour que ce
soit bien de terminer la phase est
terminée
et bien maintenant on va farcir la poule
en maïté enfourne moi ça là dedans avec
les doigts un en puissance qui va mieux
avec les doigts cuillère soit la peine
pas précis quoi alors hambourg bien on
vous rêviez pour qui elle est bien parce
que c'est bon tout le monde en veut et
puis après ça quand tu vas la prie pour
que tout ça ne fait pas longtemps que je
dois faire en cours en yole de mer à
l'éguille avec les montres nous ça
allait 8 voilà les bien sâr si c'est
bien vilain aller les grilles et un coup
comme si on faisait non les du coton
bien solide et une en aiguille et 9 ans
aiguille un noeud au boul oui en servent
à l'est la peau c'est solide ça tient
bien sûr les lâcher parce qu'il faut que
ce soit bien ouverte et quand même il
faut pas qu'elle soit ouverte importe
combien il me boulay il faut qu'elle
soit bien l'ouvrier dans l'orne pas
encore quand tu as la médaille et
attention oui quand on ouvre la poule la
terre que quand tu la vis des que fait
attention à la fin oui mais ça donne ce
qui est bien sûr et bien sûr ça peut
durer parce que le d en fait ça fait
rire autour l'habitude on sait bien que
les mains coriace à force de le faire
nous le voile est solidement fichiers
cette couleur qu'est-ce que tu en fais
maintenant make an maintenant a fait
cuire un bon alors alors on va renard le
pot qui est juste comme il faut dire que
l'eau qui sonne ah oui il faut que nos
frissonne parce que il ya une raison si
vous mettez la poule dans de l'eau
froide
vous avez le bouillon troubles avant
qu'alexis est dans l'eau chaude voilà
alors on met la poule on met les eaux
des os à moelle et serait due bouillie
de boeuf et animer ce qu'on a et une
centaine du bon goût ça ne gâche rien
après on met et le branche de thèmes pas
tellement dans le pôle grand la voie là
haut mais sako 21 oui ensuite on met
l'oignon avait le clou de girofle
oui on met les poireaux non c'est pas la
peine de les lier
on est des cons parce que non ce ferry
salah libérien voilà les je te passe les
nappes et à l'aller n'avait l'écart
ambiance
sur scène très belle trois belles
grosses qu'avant carottes et le germon
choux et les choux mais oui on peut la
main très maintenant parce que quand
même on ne mangera pas ça dans le très
bon goût et autrement le mais l'an
dernier pour qui son craquant mais la
cpo qui donne à beaucoup au delà sur la
soupe c'est les poires sel et poivre on
va pas mettre le terrain trop on
remettra le sel assez généreusement
ah mais oui on soupçonne plus un bouchon
de plus et du poivre nationale mais nous
lui avons très peur qu'ils sont très
bons il a plu beaucoup plus de saveur gm
et du poivre en poudre non ne parfume
par la voilà mon cousin qui en couvre on
va l'appuyer un petit peu le couteau
pour prouver ça peut être long cours et
puis j'ai terminé et on attend
pour accompagner la poule il faudra une
sauce alors tiens voilà une casserole
montre-nous comment tu vas faire la
sauce la sauce poulet sauce poulette
aujourd'hui en asie
alors on prend une casse ramenée sur le
feu évidemment on prend du beurre qu'on
met dans la casserole
voici un peu plus parce que moi je reste
sur deux larges quand même on met deux
mondes rubber on va accélérer le feu en
plein dans la farine
quand le beurre sur la faune du bien ça
devrait vite parce que papa qui devient
de votre cuisine en donnant aux fondus
juste rendu voilà c'était l'hymne
enterré on viendra t très facilement
quand même le départ d'une seconde mais
la farine alors deux trois petites
cuillères à sa réforme à quantité de
sauce et qu'on veut faire bientôt
tourner pour tourner avec votre fouet il
faut que le lafarie de cuisine voilà
pour tourner votre fouet bien cuit et
vous bta pas ensuite votre bouillon
la voilà ça suffit alors oui nous sommes
je raison parce que le bouillant et le
bouille alors je sens que ça va faire du
bruit montre on découvre la marmite
quand même si on prend du bruyant
l'envoyer là brouillon n'est pas grave
encore un alors vous vous êtes un grand
discours serait vous allez en allégresse
vous avez tourné en suivant vos pas que
ça fasse et des grumes en alors tourné
huit vite vite vite vite vite vite vite
vite il safran vite parce que pour
éviter que je vais faire son entrée mais
voilà alors moi pendant ce temps là
rometty de véhicules y ait encore de
bouillon et moi je vais faire et les
éditions
alors je vais prendre ce jeu sort de ça
vous allez voir pourquoi pas ce que je
vais y mettre le blâme parce que c'est
tout tu te fais ces faits salle de
secondes et 7
alors je mets les jaunes d'oeuf voilà
je coupe mon citron en deux que je vais
serrer on peut faire vêler mais on n'a
pas vraiment pressé citron vous y
arriver ou est très très bas bien oui
vous êtes gourmand de kossi la
confédération la privation avec vous
j'ai regardé et sert là je trouve que le
feu vert le fort de saint céré c'est le
brésil bcb seul c'est beaucoup de
clients se voient ça va c'est bon c'est
bon ça fait prendre très bien - joliment
citron je bats mais eux
sauf que je souhaite un peu moderne moi
je suis pas habituée au four est élégant
comme ça enfin je crois que ça va aller
quand ben il n'y a pas de grumeaux à la
bouche trou il va très bien
l'avion est très chaud alors
naturellement ça va vite ça va s'agir de
la place de la salle elie de la poivre
et le bouillon mais ça n'est pas vrai
qu'on va ça va commencer quelque part et
il faut leur c'est le trip de plus les
piles non non non c'est bon ça va
remettre la balle arrêtée
voilà et on va ajouter et je voulais se
remuer allez-y vous hérissent la voilà
revenue et raimu et remuer le merlu et
voilà regarder la couleur qu'elle a et
on appelle ça la sauce poulette c'est
quand elle est très très bien sécher en
un quart de seconde
alors on sert ça avec du riz du riz
collaborons avec la peau
et la cuy deux heures et demie
maintenant je vais la coupe est très
bien qu'est ce que tu fais je sors les
fils qui m'en servais pour la corde pour
retenir la farce c'est terminé et les
cuisses 1 où il voit les déments la
retenir un petit peu là si vous loupez
vais la jouer une priorité comme ça
l'ale bien sûr il faut pas oublier que
cette poule où l'âme en jouant avec deux
sauts sur la sauce tomate une sauce
poulette
[Musique]
et avec la polo va manger les légumes
qui ont fui dans le brouillon et du riz
qui a aussi cuit dans le bouillon et
maïté et notre sahara maintenant une
autre farce à la voilà comme une boîte
de te rendes on va lâcher
mais attention pas trop de brûler quand
même voilà là tu la mets la seule manche
a non seulement sont très bien et bien
essayé d'en faire autant nous vous le
souhaitons et nous vous disons maïté
quoi bon appétit et à très bientôt
au revoir à bientôt
[Musique]